ce samedi matin à nice des rues désertes
et des commerces fermés
et pour cause le confinement de la ville
a débuté vendredi soir à 18 heures une
mesure prise par le gouvernement face à
la flambée des cas dans le département
des alpes maritimes au taux d'incidence
les plus élevés de france qui frôle les
600 cas positifs pour cent mille
habitants
une mesure que les niçois ont accueilli
avec résignation malgré des doutes sur
son efficacité
c'est impeccable pour tout le monde
c'est paco pour nous votre passion
certainement au revoir demandes de
clients et a pris aux lacets
c'est un peu le règlement donc il faut
faire avec
je suis allé faire quelques courses
voilà je suis allé chez l'herboriste que
j'avais besoin
quant à koffi d'hommes et puis j'en ai
profité pour aller acheter mon pain et
acheter évidemment quelques quelques
gourmandises à fois là pour me faire
plaisir
j'ai pas l'impression que cela sert à
grand chose moi vous avez juste un
week-end ce mouvement reste autorisé les
déplacements pour les motifs suivants
achats de première nécessité raisons
médicales déplacements professionnels
motif familial impérieux pratique d'une
activité physique promenade est sorti
d'animaux de compagnie pour une durée
maximale d'une heure et dans un rayon de
5 km autour du domicile mais seulement
muni d'une attestation correctement
rempli au risque d'écoper d'une amende
de 135 euros et ce week-end 120
policiers ont été déployés dans la cité
azuréenne
bien décidé à ne rien laisser passer
alors le dispositif consiste à contrôler
les déplacements sur les axes principaux
du département qui soit sur la bordure
littorale qui soit sur l'autoroute ou
plus dans les terres alors depuis ce
matin ce qu'on observe avant tout c'est
une très nette diminution des volumes de
circulation on a divisé quasiment par
trois la circulation dans tout le
département quand on regarde bien ici ça
devrait être entièrement bouchonné on
voit derrière moi que healy a
relativement peu de véhicules vendredi
soir avant que les cloches sonnent les
18 heures nombreux sont les habitants
qui ont fui le littoral pour échapper
aux restrictions pour le moment seuls
deux départements français sont
concernés les alpes maritimes et le nord
mais vingt autres pourraient leur
emboîter le pas bouches du rhône var
yvelines hauts de seine réponse le 6
mars prochain a annoncé cette semaine le
premier ministre jean castex